gta online gets a big update ubisoft is
on a canceling and delaying spree plus
dragon ball the breakers finally gets a
release date
as development on gta 6 progresses
rockstar continues to support gta online
with significant updates the newest of
these is criminal enterprises a free
expansion coming july 26th a line from
the expansion's description reads quote
the southern san andreas economy is in
crisis gas prices have spiked to their
highest level in decades retail supply
chains are in turmoil and to top it all
off a ferocious heatwave is gripping the
state sounds oddly familiar in the
expansion you will take on a new mission
called operation paper trail as an agent
of the international affairs agency to
see if the dugan petrochemical family
are deliberately manipulating the fuel
market the criminal enterprises
expansion is also described as a
sweeping update that kicks off a series
of additions bringing new modes vehicles
collectibles and special events to the
game throughout the rest of the summer
any gta online player who owns an
executive office will find a new staff
manager lupe who can help you find
special cargo additionally executives
can now take on new missions there are
also new clubhouse contracts for players
who have a clubhouse with the custom
bike shop elsewhere the criminal
enterprises expansion adds more resupply
missions that challenges players to rob
targets to get more gear for nightclub
owners there is a new contract to take
on to acquire new goods and wares beyond
all of this rockstar says that fans
should keep an eye out for a
comprehensive list of new gameplay and
experience improvements across all of
gta online rockstar will share further
details on the gameplay and balance
changes of criminal enterprises on july
26th when the expansion arrives and as
usual this update is coming to ps5 4
xbox one series x and s and pc but not
to playstation 3 and xbox 360. in other
news bandai namco has confirmed dragon
ball the breakers will release on
october 14th the game pits seven
survivors non-powered human characters
against one player controlled by iconic
villains the game pits seven survivors
non-player human characters against one
player controlling iconic villains or
raiders from across the dragon ball
universe the seven must survive until
the end of the match using items and
perks against the villain who wins by
eliminating all other players a network
test for dragon ball the breakers was
also confirmed which will take place on
august 5th and 6th across four sessions
the times for these are as follows i'm
only reading off the eastern times but i
will include all in the description
below august 5th from 10 p.m eastern to
2 a.m eastern august 6th from 8 a.m 2 12
p.m 2 p.m to 6 p.m and 10 pm to 2 am
switching gears to avatar frontiers of
pandora announced today as part of its
earnings briefing ubisoft revealed the
new avatar game will not launch on
schedule and is now aiming for release
next fiscal year which begins april 1st
2023 and ends on june 30th 2024 and
frontiers of pandora isn't the only
ubisoft game being delayed as it was
also confirmed that a smaller
unannounced premium game has shifted to
next fiscal year as well aside from the
delays ubisoft also revealed that two
other unannounced games have been
cancelled as well as splinter cell vr
and ghost recon frontlines the good news
though is that the future of assassin's
creed will be revealed during an event
this september but alright on a scale of
one to ten let me know how excited you
are for this avatar game i haven't
really heard anyone talking about it
doesn't seem like the hype is way up
there so i'm dying to know what your
feelings are about it and i'll see you
tomorrow